so I already told you about Donald Trump
with another example of his just
terrible judgment initially saying that
he's fine with the North Korean missile
launch that later he says didn't
actually happen this is a serious
concern or at least it should be for the
movement that cares about rationality
and critical thinking and modern
geopolitical relationships and really
everything else under the umbrella of
what I like to call reality if you care
about reality if you want to operate in
a world where reality influences our
views and decisions and our sort of
place in the world as humans then you
have to recognize that the fact that
there's something very wrong with Donald
Trump's judgment is an existential risk
to the United States and when we look
back at all of these examples of trumps
poor judgment I mean just to give you a
few Trump's repeated statements that he
believed Russian President Vladimir
Putin that Russia didn't interfere in
the 2016 US election that was Trump
using what he believes to be his good
judgment which is not to read a guy like
Vladimir Putin and to come away saying I
believe him I trust them I think he's
telling me the truth of course we now
have endless dozens and dozens of
assessments and the Moller report and
everything else which tells us actually
American intelligence conclusions were
right from the beginning about Russian
interference that one we talk about a
lot we just talked about the North Korea
example five minutes ago Trump said he
doesn't think that Kim jong-un and the
regime did anything in violation of the
UN Security Council resolutions with the
recent launch you'll remember that
Donald Trump also said he doesn't
believe that anybody high up at North
Korea in North Korea had anything to do
with or even awareness of what happened
with the death of otto warmbier remember
when Donald Trump said this I know the
warmbier family very well I think
they're an incredible family what
happened is horrible
I really believe something very bad
happened to him and I don't think that
the top leadership know about it and
when they had to send him home by the
way I got the prisoners back I got the
hostages back and Otto was one of the
hostages but I don't came back
shape that was not even to be talked
about I find it I thought it was
horrible now the others came back
extremely healthy but Otto came back in
a condition that was just just terrible
and I will I did speak about it and I
don't believe that he would have allowed
that to happen just wasn't to his
advantage to allow that to happen
kim jeong-hoon or at least the top
leadership knows when there are
Americans being held in North Korea
their value is huge to the North Korean
propaganda machine and it is an
absolutely absurd assertion that Donald
Trump made and another example of his
poor judgment there's lots of other
examples where it's more a question of
is Trump's judgment bad or is he just
dumb like when he said Mexico's going to
pay for the wall any sensible person
realized they were never going to pay
for it
it just wasn't going to happen and
Donald Trump insisted that they were is
that bad judgment is that being dumb is
that deliberately lying I'm not really
sure Trump had the bad judgment to
choose Michael Flynn as a national
security adviser despite having been
warned multiple times by multiple people
including Barack Obama about Michael
Flynn we know how that ended with
Michael Flynn indicted Trump had the bad
judgment to attack John McCain endlessly
even after John McCain died the
disastrous judgment which led Trump to
start this endless unwinnable trade war
with China which allows Russia to swoop
in and improve their relationship with
China increasingly leaving the United
States out to pasture the limitless bad
judgment of violating the Iran deal even
though Iran didn't violate the deal
which as I told you two weeks ago is now
leading Iran to resume researching
nuclear technology predictable and an
internally logical move from Iran's
point of view and the more I think about
it I actually don't know whether these
are examples of bad judgment or of Trump
being simply ignorant or of Donald Trump
being a bad person but in either case
it's the mother lode of bad decisions
and bad position
that are coming from Donald Trump's
inability or unwillingness to actually
judge situations for what they are
we're sort of in a 1984 esque era in
that way I know that in the last couple
years I've said that a lot of elements
of what's going on today are less like
1984 and more like brave new world by
Aldous Huxley this particular thing is
more a 1984 thing right war is peace
freedom is slavery ignorance is strength
everything's backwards nothing is as it
seems and Donald Trump even said that
trying to remember something like what
you were seeing and hearing you
shouldn't believe or you can't believe
what you were seeing and hearing it's
good to be back from my vacation and my
trip because we've got to get down to
business with removing this menace
because it is becoming extraordinarily
belligerent and significantly more
urgent particularly as these long-term
relationships are broken and bad
decisions are made and it's going to
take whoever replaces Trump Bibi it in
two years I guess more like a year and a
half now whether it's in a year and a
half or in five and a half years whoever
ultimately replaces Donald Trump is
going to have years of work to do to fix
the problems that Donald Trump has
created make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on Instagram to vote
in this week's poll at David Pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much much more right after this
it's great to be back